cet abattoir est spécialisée dans la
mise à mort des truies de réforme c'est
rui ont passé leur courte vie dans un
élevage intensif a donné naissance à des
porcelets après trois années passées
dans ces terribles conditions épuisé
blessées elles sont envoyées à
l'abattoir trop faible pour se déplacer
certaines sont électrocutés directement
leur arrivée à l'abattoir elle s'est
ensuite relié au dessus des vivante
jusqu'au poste de saigner s'est rué
paralysé pourtant et les poussées de
force à coup d'aiguillon électrique à
travers les couloirs de l'abattoir ici à
l'entrée de couloir de la mort les
truies paniqués tentent de résister
elles sont frappées expliqué à maintes
reprise pour les faire avancer plus vite
un employé applique l'aiguillon dans
l'anus détruits merci la seule vega loin
d'être avec nous merci vous êtes
méditant t et activiste et baptiste
marché vous êtes viandards c'est quoi
voilà oui à tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure vous avez dit que j'étais fort
de france j'ai entendu dans la loge
voilà c'est faux je suis record de
france nous développer coûts chez ba
pour moi tu es l'homme seul mort de sens
qui pourra le dire tu pourras faire le
beau temps alors merci d'être avec nous
la faire de l'abattoir condom vient de
voir les images a fait énormément parler
faut-il interdire les abattoirs oui non
solveig vous forcément c'est oui il
interdire un génocide industriels est-ce
que de poser la question c'est pas déjà
être complice du plus grand cri henri
masse de l'histoire de pas maintenant
maintenant posez la question c'est aussi
être complice donc on pose la question
déjà soir on avait déjà au moins 16 sept
franchement bon on pose la question
moderniser treblinka
non mais pose une question c'est la même
pas honte de la france bernard gines
alcide vous rendez compte des gens qui
ont vraiment vécu ça dans leur histoire
dans leur passé ce qu'ils pensent la
boulimie formation d'un meurtre de masse
mais et son exécution puisque en fait
les truites qui sont dans cette vidéo où
tout le monde m'accordera qu'elles sont
bien assassiné c'était un meurtre
prémédité génocide puisque ce sont des
gens donc ils sont voilà génocide
bah écoutez moi je suis en forme je suis
évidemment contre tout ce qui fait sur
l'animal mais commencé comme ça en
comparant bah oui avec treblinka avec un
génocide avec le non jeu franchement là
vous dire de badens pied vous êtes bien
en une phrase en oeuvre alors une et non
je vous dis petit je fais uniquement
dans une phrase et six prévenus ont fini
en une fois que vous vous en faites vous
je savais dès le départ que moi
j'entends ça j'avais les jambes pour moi
je rentre toujours dans ça vous dit de
fond du coeur avec toi je sais ce que
j'ai vécu
j'ai envie de te quitter le plateau oui
avec wind parce que les deux femmes est
très bien qu'ils aient un mot simple et
ça ça me l'année dernière les ricains
c'est un livre de sirop d'érable et de
moore et j'ai envie de vomir quand
j'entends ça c'est non on de dire ça
c'est d'un autre côté personne qu'on
pense et c'est bien pire ce sont des
milliards de 20 ans et que vous jouerez
y clôture le débat qui avait insulté la
mémoire des personnes qui ont des
humaines qui ont subi à chaud mais ça
qu'il faut le comparatif
soyez un peu plus et redis c'est pour ça
qu'ils seraient allés à la pointe de la
lutte animalistes parce que les déçus
rennais sur yvon sortant des camps ont
dit que c'était la même chose ce n'est
pas moi qui la filme donc vous insulter
la mémoire des sapiens qui ont subi en
holocauste holocauste qui veut dire
faire brûler qu'est ce que vous voyez en
face de vous quel est ce que c'est un
homme quand est-ce que cet autre chose
je vous demande de me décrire ce que
vous voyez je sais pas je vais regarder
est-ce que ça ce n'est pas en sommes
encore jeunes gens une victime innocente
viol issu d'un viol qui a été violée
toute sa vie qui a si bien marathon
geste hâtif qui a subi qui a été d
enfanter toute sa vie qui n'a subi que
torture génétique multi nation et
exécutions dans les camps de la mort
s'il vous plaît solveig connais moi le
mot adéquat disent mon film à décrire ça
alors maintenant nous sommes dans un
déni sociétal vous et beaucoup d'autres
nous
animal nous soutiennent dans mes
positions mondiales et à l'abolition
universelle cette boucherie c'est
mauvais qu'on va driver tirez vous du
businessman masculin ça c'est dommage
que vous parlez comme ça moi j'aime les
animaux je me protège g d'émission sur
les animaux pour les manger aussi
peut-être calamité madame vous êtes une
hystérique on va pas parler parce que
vous écrivez cette façon vous avez de
décrire c'est contre vous raconter
n'importe quoi
c'est dramatique je me fous complètement
de ce qu'il voit il n'y a qu'un qui
compte il n'y a qu'elle me laisse
entrevoir une hystérie voilà non mais
vous êtes décrit pas de moi monsieur de
millions d'individus et non madame
imaginez moi à souhait notre colère ne
tarira jamais notre colère sont guéris
et nos larmes c'est ben ali nous sommes
témoins et vous voulez un débat posé
nous sommes au delà de ça vous donnez
commencé avec moi ce que je veux d
hystérie jeu solveig de nicolas ne sais
pas ça mais là c'est complètement ce que
vous dites mais il n'y a pas un débat à
mener calmement si c'est jugé parce que
ça me fait mal intégristes vous avez pas
interdire à tous les gens de manger de
la viande par exemple même si c'est ce
qu'ils voudraient species ou l'abolition
universelle de l'ado s'agit bien sûr
voilà là aujourd'hui on est en train de
dire à tout le monde a bien fallu
yamamah morges allaman que nous aurons à
cette guerre qui constate amer
oui nicolas mais non mais effectivement
vous pénalisez enfin vous aviez vous
arrivez à rien défendre en disant des
propos pareils c'est complètement mais
vous êtes centre en ayant entendu parler
faire mon trou d'aix vous êtes des
nasillard vous désirez
non mais vous rendez compte de ce que
madame est en train de virer cours les
victimes maison ma vie ce que j'ai fait
ce que j'exagère vis-à-vis des victimes
mais non mais attendez après ont résonné
dans les manifs réseau mais raisonné
faudrait c'est un très beau monsieur
dans les camps nous on est tous dans le
garde à vue on est tout le temps procès
on est tout le temps en prison on va
libérer les truies détenus qui sont
maires assassinés dans les camps de la
mort et bien la police vient nous
chercher
non mais la résistance en prison non
mais en fait ce que c'est que ce que
cette jeune fille dit pardon ton prénom
excuse-moi important au-delà gothique
justement elle rend le truc pas un port
louis la de ses cris il faut entendre ce
qu'elle dit effectivement ces animaux
c'est des victimes
nan mais c'est absolument enrichissement
juste j'ai préparé un peu des trucs vous
m'excusez donc faut-il interdire les
abattoirs en l'état oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui 80% les abattoirs sont
jugées non conformes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire non conforme
par exemple une truie qui est épuisé on
lui met un aiguillon électrique dans
l'anus pour qu'elle avance on lui met un
aiguillon électrique dans les yeux pour
qu'elles reculent série ne s'est pas du
tout drôle
je ne rigole pas du tout un poulet par
exemple les poulets l'aller poulet aux
hormones avant de les tuer on les
accroche par les pattes ils sont le
corps est tellement lourd que les pâtes
cède voyez ce que je veux dire
il a beaucoup travaillé mais les noms
mais les faut savoir que les cochons ils
sont plus intelligents que les chiens
les cochons ensemble des batteries dans
ces régions
c'est absolument horrible et aujourd'hui
91 % des français sont contre l'élevage
intensif donc on est tous acteurs et
tous consommateurs
il suffirait cyril que deux jours par
semaine on soit végétarien deux jours
par semaine c'est bien pensée on
économise 350 millions dire quelque
chose ça choque tout le monde ces images
wii console bègue arrive et qu'elle nous
traitent villes d'asie et qu'elle dit
qu'on ne devrait pas poser la question
est là c'est les gens là le mérite de la
pause et on a le mérite de montrer ces
images à une heure de grande écoute en
pour sensibilisation répondre abonnés
sont universellement vers la douleur et
n'allez pas john may cry madame
entendent aller il n'y a pas de mots
pour décrire cette abomination tout à
fait logique on à celle attendue courant
+2 le cri est une expression juste et la
colère également
j'essaie d'être qui n'est pas juste
c'est le sait le ton modéré
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une
possibilité quand nous sommes dans la
fin du monde
nous sommes dans l'au delà des mots nous
sommes dans la banalité du mal comme
autorisé s'il vous plaît aidez-moi la
donne dans la banalité du bateau faisait
dorsale bon seul bug dans l'est comme la
main deux minutes une est une torture
mais là vous allez vous enverra six ans
comme un débat je sais c'est en nous
sommes en situation d'un chat crime et
que post traumatique 12 salves éclatant
votre combat mais c'est au delà de notre
vie vous pensez bien que je me fous du
bon ton d'un plateau télé
nous sommes au delà
[Musique]
mais le pire
interrompant le pire reprenons la
résistance là où elles sont peu près ça
va le faire c'est bon là stop c'est un
peu plus vague à sont pas voir la vie
non
baptiste allez-y vous entre vous donner
alors on s'en régale donc alors oui
alors ce qui se passe c'est que
effectivement le ce que montre l214 je
pense que c'est utile est en fait une
version pas si je le soutiens je
soutiens une force grâce à un écran ça
coûte cher et grands sacs étaient pas ça
c'est une histoire de leur combat est
utile c'est vrai parce qu'il faut que
les français voient ça aussi parce que
danton dépensé se cacher les yeux
vis-à-vis de ça c'est vrai oui que 80%
des abattoirs en france c'est ça ou le
comprendre et c'est toute la chaîne
agroalimentaire qu'il faut changer de
l'élevage à l'abattage encore résistants
de vrais résistants pas comme l214
vous avez des éleveurs qui travaille
correctement si vous avez encore des
abattoirs filière française des
abattoirs l'analyse et qui endorment les
animaux d'accord avant de les abattre il
existait à bateau et je connais je sais
que je connais et tétouan de bond qui
gérait ce déjà que je fais mais par
trois qui partent de l'oise de gueule du
le val d'oise pour aller jusqu'au bout
de la picardie trouver un abattoir et
passe devant trois abattoirs avant de
trouver un abattoir correct pour et
leurs bêtes il ya des éleveurs qui font
ce travail là il faut les valoriser ce
qu'il faut expliquer aux français c'est
tout
vous voyez des pubs qui vous disent de 0
2 kg de côte de porc il faut que les
français comprennent que quand ils
achètent ce prix là c'est ça qu'ils
achètent et il faut pas les il faut pas
les traumatiser comme vous le savez il
faut pas leur imputer alors que les
droits plus de pouvoirs dont il s'envole
pour la belle une mort c'est une mort
comme les baleines à tout le monde
la nature et funny nature fn alimentaire
on comprend on comprend ce qu'il ya dans
le regard mais ces pillages
moi je moi moi j'ai jamais dit non mais
t'es déjà arrêter d'inventer des moutons
c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui tous les scientifiques le
disent parce que laurent coste débat est
arrêté c'est pas pousser mais la
direction avait des nations mais oui du
mar dans les mails à vous faites c'est
contre-productif même pourrait-on pilar
c'est vous changer les choses pour
peines allégées vous pensez pas la
colère ne marchait pas le calme ne
marche pas c'est baptiste prisonniers
notamment la police qui ne précise pas
qui nous met en prison les i messieurs
dames vous êtes seul vous serez vous la
colère ne sera jamais au niveau sonore
c'est bon de dire tu dois te suis
sujets nationaux il faut abolir
universellement le second dry le règne
de m possesseur qui ont vu six millions
d'individus
ces machines à produire de la viande
c'était loin c'est le soldat a été sacré
tout scénarisé marathon geste hâtif
on l'a désormais la présidence ont
soulevé les règles et c'est parler les
autres ses congénères dans les camps
d'exécution caméra qu'est ce que ça
change
vous ferra snuff movies gens non ce
magot salgas agassi et vous si vous
plongez maféré corps mais c'est pas ce
soir sortez du bon temps c'est pas ce
soir c'est une fois demande qui
s'orchestre avenue jean-moulin pandémie
vient de la vue du masque du vaccin vous
êtes ridicule honda vient des épisodes
aussi les éleveurs sont des provocateurs
de doula des provocateurs de maladie
c'est un peu long pour les gens curieux
arrêtez avec moi moi je retiens un truc
de ce que vous avez dit baptiste et là
je rejoins sur le bec sur laquelle sur
ce qu'elle va le dire parce que oui
solberg son combat alors solberg elle
était victime
je ne sais pas enfermé toute la journée
elle en valait bien gb 10 baptistes et
c'est vrai qu'on est nombreux à
rejoindre l'un combat détruit bien sûr
sévira le biais de solveig aussi évident
ou pas non mais non mais c'est vrai mais
le sourire donc vous avez dit un truc
c'est que 80% des abattoirs ne
respectent pas les règles etc vous savez
même ceux qui respectent les règles
suprême soutien et ce mec les règles
sont compliquées pour un vrai on dise
que loco locass et qui comme ça non
ma main ça mais c'est vrai que même avec
des règles s'appliquent pas bien se
passer non messieurs samedi dont le
réformer mais bon est-ce que vous êtes
conscient que c'est quand même une
immense majorité des français croient
que c'est 95% qui mangent de la viande
donc vous traitez 95% des français de
criminels avec les sénateurs et les
séminaires sont pas d'accord dans vos
d'avion l'autre j'avais laissé ma
terminé s'il vous plaît au lieu d'être
agressive est-ce que vous avez des
solutions s'est s'amélioré solution de
l'élevage
voilà le 100% végétale
j'ai maintenant vingt jeunes pâtissent
le but a été légalisé monsieur la même
chose on n'avait qu'à laisser tous les
juifs vont mourir dans les cordes arrêté
les fous dit sorte de contre et me
cachant ptz dans les soldats sont des
vasques combat c'est quoi votre combat
ce que vous dites là vous affaiblissez
votre combat est très clair mais je me
bats contre le racisme je me bats contre
le sexisme brushing à 90 comme vous avez
raison vous avez raison on ne sait rien
on est là la raison mais pour l'avion
c'est bien de visio encore l'exécution
sais pas si je vais monter en france
avec bordeaux locaux brûlé brûlé way to
play vous calmez vous paraît pas tout
seul instant au bal à ckoi séjourné
longtemps dans votre assiette en message
si je peux dire le coup de balayette
savez gros nettement votre cause est la
mienne depuis longtemps sauf que une
cause et réussi quand on a envie de
suivre la personne et quand vous parlez
c'est tout le monde dans tous les sens
dans tous les courants qu'on ne peut pas
suivre cet aliment
on a fait une de vincent lille etc on
l'a fait 30 ans qu'on faisait coiffer
300 points 10 pour moi la fête tout le
monde s'en fout non ya urgence
chaque jour qui vous prendrez part je
veux pas parler chaque seconde qui passe
quand vous croyez qu'on a le temps mais
on crions pas de calendrier pour la
justice est ce qu'en criant la calandre
et y entraient attendez quoi tu
il a de ce fait été constaté que tout
était en fait j'étais en train de
s'autodétruire
parce que là c'est on vous entendez être
commentée batterie secrète des vortex de
fioles pressé par les regarder les
charniers d'entente et la ferme du monde
s'est remplie vague qui s'affale avec
mam est saoul et là je vous dis jamais
joué au foot vous ne répondez pas déjà
vous fait des comparaisons qui sont
inadmissibles
sous les toits révèle ici pour gueuler
c'est donc un sujet suivant les bains
vous nous gonfler je regardais solveig
il faut que vous puissiez écouter insu
on peut poser la question non mais bon
vous avez du mal à vous donner tout ce
que l'on peut on peut vous dire sur moi
je soutiens c'est un massacre des
animaux bas et oui je vous soutiens
venus diantre aux animaux louisiane
vous en êtes chanceux mais nous sommes
tous des amis c'est vrai so lu ment mais
vous pouvez juste nous écouter en vous
disant que les infusions à treblinka au
camp rouge 8,2 propos
chacun sa vraie carrière la cause non je
perds la consommation yves adam kane sur
quoi les camps de humeur était calqué
sur l'élevage imlach et et éleveurs
n'ont été il faut soyons concrets
prochain même architecture que je fais
tu changes
managua changeons les abattoirs il faut
les changer
vidéo dans les abattoirs contrôler ce
qui s'y passe
[Musique]
audrey solvay se faire dès aujourd'hui
se lever et de caméras oui cela par les
solberg c'est la part des non matches il
n'a pas parlé moi je suis complètement
perdue parce que je trouve effectivement
ces images insoutenables
comme nous tous yeux comme mais comme
gilles verdez que malgré tout moi
j'adore manger un steak mais parce qu'il
ya d'autres il faut le dire aux français
n'a d'autre façon continue et gémit faux
frais survolant je sais que j'ai fait et
bien grand bien vous fasse davantage à
montboucher lolo qui est absolument
adorable qui a beaucoup de respect pour
ab bien ça leur est rappelé que j'ai ou
est ce qu'on arrive il faut les
catacombes de l'obscénité de cynisme et
ses bouquets je souffre d'une boucherie
c'est pas c'est terrible pour nous cette
image est terrible mais la région la
côte de porc elle vient de là
ça voulait pas entendre la côte de porc
ne vienne mois d'élevage comme ça votre
pédiatre bien sûr diamant pas de porc
d'ailleurs bien sûr j'ai fait delphine
est ce que je consomme ça vient pas de
la libye je suis dit comme chedjou trois
breaks se bat non seulement par de
jeunes parce que je suis avec vous a
aussi un sauf que je parle beaucoup plus
audible que mada alors géraldine comme
tu dis oui mais moi je suis dans le
plaisir gustatif pas moi aussi je le
suis et tu sais qu'aujourd'hui il ya par
exemple la vraie fourrure la fausse
fourrure qui est tout aussi belle il ya
aussi les phostech maintenant à base
végétale
ils ont je ne fais même pas les manger
tellement que ça boulgour et de la
graine de cours je n'ai que tout le
monde et les autres juste manger à ne
pas trop manger bien du mal à 17h au
moins je vous le redis ces carnivores et
bien sûr savent rien parce qu'ils
connaissaient l'auraient bâtisse
baptiste qu'est ce que tu veux dire
moi ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est que
en vérité c'est dommage qu'ils aient des
gens comme ça dans le débat parce qu'en
fait moi mon combat il est aussi pour
les animaux contrairement à ce que
madame peut croire sauf que moi j'essaie
d'avoir un combat raisonnée et il est
pas que pour les animaux puisque vous
dites qu'on est tous des animaux mais
vous pensez aux éleveurs comptent tous
les éleveurs qui se suicident alors sur
l'aca compte pas cela c'est vrai comment
celui-ci d'aussi à cause de ça il
succède ainsi à cause de ça parce qu'il
veut car plus de vendre leur bétail et
donc
c'est moi c'est nous laissez-moi tenir
laissez moi je retiens moi j'ai encore
toute ma voix chocs les plus forts que
vous laissez moi finir centre et non pas
avec séparatistes à tartiner blais on
n'est pas venu voir votre swing man show
on est venu tordre et des jantes
éligibles non c'est une peine totale je
vous laisserai plus parler sérieusement
tant que c'est pas la peine que je
ressens
non là non
ton ce cadre là pas de bras d'honneur
c'est pas très copines en eux
s'il vous plaît bassiste noel baptiste
présenter non juste je fais ce savon ça
faisait très intelligent et tout et vous
posez la question à marc amant moi je
veux juste reprendre des grandes
personnes dans l'histoire qui se sont
posé la question sur pourquoi manger ou
pourquoi tuer des animaux et sont tous
devenir végétarien juste à temps plein
d'eau chez nous en reconnaissez
quelqu'un conficius pythagore mais
darwin gandhi einstein franchement
d'algues ou juste un truc voie à
d'autres statues végétariens les
chiffres des mois d'attenté ça veut rien
dire mais trouver des gens tu vas t'il
c'était des groupes des grandes
personnes vous savez ce que c'est le dj
s'est tu pendant quelques instants
je vous laisse le mot de la fin
bah oui parce que simplement du début si
nous sommes la lutte ce n'est pas
universellement les bars à vin la bière
le plus vite possible
chaque seconde compte non non c'est pour
ça nous devons saisir sa déjà des
millions de pages
lisons tous les jours au sommet des
villes laissées par les meilleurs bobo à
huy passé 5 vous je t'ai dis clairement
je vous avais bien sûr que non et du
quart
oui la 34 % non 66% regardez le vent
n'ont peut-être ce passionné pas crier
assez fort solberg en a dix secondes
alors la dimension universelle
le système de la domination masculine
qui s'approprie pour produire des
millions d'individus et les transformer
en viande
voilà merci soldats merci m cela n'en
détruit le seul combat contre bon bah je
suis triste et je suis comme ça merci
solveig d'avoir été avec nous